[Music]
i'm attorney general ashley moody
with a warning about contact tracing
scams
health officials in florida are calling
people who may have been in contact with
someone who tested positive
for coven 19. it's extremely important
that they make contact with potentially
infected individuals
to help slow the spread of this deadly
disease
making contact tracing vital to ending
this pandemic
sadly scammers are mimicking these calls
in an attempt to steal personal
information
if you receive a call from someone who
claims to be a contact tracer
take steps to confirm that the call is
in fact from your local health
department
know that a legitimate contact tracer
will never ask for your birth date
they already have this information and
will simply ask for confirmation
contact tracers will never ask for your
social security number
or banking information they have that
too they also will never reveal the
identity of the coveted 19 positive
person
you may have had contact with so what
the [ __ ] the point finally if a call
seems suspicious
hang up your local health
get her out of here this is again an
attack on
entrepreneurs people reaching out to
other people
to do business to drive the economy
it's about commerce and if people want
to call people
and and and and and and present and say
hey
you might have been in contact with
somebody who had covert 19 get a test
and then use it as a way to present them
with a business opportunity
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that and shame on the attorney
general of florida
shame on her shame on her for that
anti-business attitude
shame on her how dare she we all don't
get checks from the government
we all don't get checks from uncle sam
some of us need to go out in the streets
and earn a living
bring home the bacon rustle up a little
cabbage and
what in it what is she doing she's
discouraging men like myself
i got to list the names of florida i'm
just going to call all of them and let
them know they might have been in touch
with somebody
who has covert 19. the fact that
scammers
are using the contact tracing uh to to
try to scam people
is just it's i know it's sad
but it is so funny that it's happening
like it's so
funny to me that they're cause i mean
people we would have done that we've
been like hey how are you hey is this
miss miller yes
listen it's never an easy call to make
but we just want to let you know that
you may have been in contact with
somebody who's tested positive for coven
19. we have it
on some good information that you've
exposed yourself and your family to this
potentially devastating disease
have you taken a covet 19 test well good
news is
we can show up at the property with the
covet 19 test you and the entire family
for for seven easy payments of 69.99
also what rate are you paying on the
mortgage
mortgage rates have dropped
precipitously due to the economic
climate is there a way
that we can help you streamline some of
your debt
and refinance that property in florida
while we're testing your family for
covet 19 i think that's the smartest
thing
to do am i wrong here mrs miller i don't
think i
am and then we would just show up
we'd show up you know
drug the family yeah make her sign all
these papers
and then light them on fire and if that
is not
america then i don't want to live here
anymore i don't want to live in a
country
where i cannot first of all if you're
answering a contact tracing call
i don't know maybe stop
do you really feel better if it's the
government going hello
uh it's the government uh
were you your sister's house last
wednesday because there was a party and
three people have
coveted and what
contact tracing is too late it's too
late
i mean you have it or you don't i guess
yep just wear the [ __ ] mask
all of this is to avoid the dumb mask
and and the mask is only because you
people want to leave your homes
so be very easy don't leave
don't wear the mask don't go anywhere
unless you have to go to work and then
you you have to wear the mask because
you're at work
but it's this idea that you're like oh i
want to go out i don't want to wear them
and then we have all of these other
things now where it's like well
now we have contact tracing and you know
they're going to use that as they
already have for protesters and
everybody else and
you didn't pay your taxes last year or
you said the word i
said inappropriate word on facebook now
it's contact tracing
and wait wait till that starts wait till
social justice contact tracing starts
they start calling people
hi you like to tweet uh last thursday
is there sharon is there sharon
did you tweet last thursday hey dr fauci
we know what you did with aids and
you're not gonna do it again
we're just trying to trace all the
different people you've been in contact
with
the different people that might hold
those opinions
it's bad i'm not answering a call from
the government i don't want i don't want
anybody calling me i don't want my
friends and family
calling me i certainly i'm thinking
about moving and it's just such a great
boomer attitude i was thinking about
moving
and uh my father goes it's closer to
where he i mean he's in new york i
wouldn't be in california anymore
and uh my father's whole thing uh of
course the perfect boomer response to
me thinking about starting my new life
he goes well yeah it would be easier for
me to visit you
because i wouldn't have to fly all the
way down california so again
thank you uh thank you just a great way
they will always make it about
themselves uh
as much as possible you got to respect
it you almost
have to respect it truly you know
and it would be easier to respect if
that type of attitude
didn't destroy civilization uh
as it rapidly crumbles rapidly crumbling
dhs agents
un uh going around portland snatching
people
up if you've seen this a little
disturbing
but i mean portland's crazy there's a
lot of loonies
running around there but still
uncomfortable with people getting thrown
into vans by the government but again we
knew this was gonna happen
everybody i mean again the most
predictable thing
ever um they had barely made it up half
a block when an unmarked minivan pulled
up in front of them i see guys in camo
four or five of them pop up open the
door and it was just like oh [ __ ]
i don't know who you are or what you
want with us federal law enforcement
officers
have been using unmarked vehicles to
drive around downtown portland and
detain
protesters since last tuesday personal
accounts and multiple videos posted
online
show the officers driving up to people
detaining individuals with no
explanation about why they're
being arrested and driving off i mean
this is this was started after 9 11 this
type of thing we do not have to
give you a reason as to why you were
being detained are we going to hold you
indefinitely
this is exactly what uh you know people
were afraid of and of course a lot of
people are probably
saying that these people are domestic
terrorists and they were planning on
committing
acts of domestic terrorism i don't know
if that's true it's certainly not
impossible
the people in portland are out of their
[ __ ] minds some of them
so absolutely it's possible but again
it's like we got to just take the
government's word for it
and we got to just show up in a van and
throw people in a van it just doesn't
seem
this this seems like you know it heads
to a bad place
is it just me is it just me or the camo
guys
throwing people in a van and driving off
heads to a bad place but what did i tell
you in the beginning of this thing
i said the riots and the looting what
are they going to be used for
they're going to be used as a way for
the government to take whatever few
remaining rights you have
this is not new this shouldn't be
surprising
that's why i was like protests are great
non-violent
protests are great the minute you use
violence the state turns around
and will use violence as well and so the
logical thing there is
if you think violence is going to work
you have to believe
that you're going to beat the state
that you're going to actually drive the
state
i mean out of portland
i mean how long did chazz last two weeks
they've got one by city hall right now
everybody's just hanging out doing drugs
discussing what the new government will
be like
i you know after the city falls it
doesn't work
it doesn't work because the government's
got the money and the power and
the weaponry and machinery of death
they have the i mean we have a
population
but but it's also like there's there's
no
loyalty that anybody in this country has
to anybody else we're not a
a group of people that agree on anything
we're not we're not going to be able to
fashion a government
i mean this is child stuff i mean this
is like a crazy idea
the idea that we're going to like topple
the government and then we're going to
like everybody
we're going to people are gonna sit
around a room and then
decide what the new government's gonna
look like
after we've burned the white house down
i mean and i see people that
should be more intelligent than this
egging this on
pouring gasoline on this and i keep
wondering and asking them like well what
is the plan here
what is the plan we abolish the police
then enrich communities private cops
ex-massad xcia
fun folks less accountability than the
cops have now
and in the poor communities who will
fill that power vacuum
the mafia gangs criminal enterprises
because businesses people are going to
want
safety and security and somehow they're
going to get it and the only way they'll
get it is by
pledging loyalty to uh some type of
criminal enterprise
this is what happens when the police are
gone
and then the state no longer has a
monopoly on violence and that
everybody's using violence
in his vigilante way as they see fit
everybody else this is the anarchy
that uh we fetishize on twitter all the
time
the same people that fetishize this type
of anarchy get very scared
when someone misgenders someone they
think that's violence wait till they
find out what actual violence is
the same people get scared that somebody
doesn't use the right pronouns in a
magazine or somebody has an argument
that disagrees with them feel perfectly
comfortable with people marching through
the streets
burning down uh buildings
thinking this is all going to go to some
i mean
it's [ __ ] wild that
these are adults this is
[ __ ] nuts that we're having these
conversations
with i get drug addict failed
stand-up comedians who live on floors
but uh i'm i'm looking at actual adults
celebrities people with money
thinking that somehow these mass
violent insurrections in these cities
lead to anything good
is everyone nuts
this is like that thing went viral on
facebook that guy tom foolery
we talked about it on the patreon he did
that
he did that um he did that thing when
the quarantine
first started um the like
you know the bread making on instagram
was happening everybody was baking bread
and
everybody was talking about how the
earth was healing
and we were going to emerge stronger
than before how did that how did that
work out
are we stronger than before um and then
this guy
it went viral this guy tom fool i don't
even know who he is but he's this
british guy
and he he can we play that on the show
no we did on the patreon though we did
another picture we can't play but
basically it was like a
a rhyme where he's reading a book to a
son or a kid
and he's like we built cities with
buildings very tall
but we weren't listening to each other
at all
and then he would do this whole thing
about how like you know and then
you know people got sick and we we
started listening we started dancing
we started baking and take and he was
like and it was just like this [ __ ]
crazy pollyanna-ish view
of like what would happen when you told
the country they couldn't go to work
tomorrow
they're like everybody will start
dancing in the street until
and yeah that works for a week and then
all of a sudden uh
it starts to get pretty dark pretty
quick but
i mean i just don't understand if
somebody could explain to me if somebody
intelligent can explain to me
how they think this all works great
i'm open the list i'm open to listening
okay
i'm open to it
i think chrissy teigen should lean in to
being accountable
at this point because she's probably not
but all of twitter
a lot of twitter thinks she is so just
lean into it and have john legend get
out and be like
we're just ordinary cannibals
and sit on the [ __ ] piano while he
does it who cares
chrissy teigen's just a hot chick listen
cueing on people i all i try to do is
help you people i really do all
many of you are schizophrenic many of
you are schizophrenic
many of you have a few of the right
ideas and a lot of the wrong ones
and that's a potent combination and it's
quite bad
it's quite bad to have some of the right
ideas and
some of the wrong ones and just go
confidently with that
[Music]
not good so chris tegan
i don't even know who the she's like a
model who married john legend
she's on social media all the time
and she's a hot chick who just ki the
biggest problems in life
listen to me now you see how i did that
with my voice that means i'm going to a
philosopher
mode the biggest problems in life
are people that can't be who they are
rich
people that can't just be rich and try
to be like
clowns you look at them with pity
and you look on in horror i've seen rich
people on stage like trying to do it
and kiss nothing sadder than watching a
rich person
fail at trying to be a clown there's
nothing worse than a
hot chick trying to be funny and
relevant and interesting if you don't
have to be
she's a hot chick who's addicted to
herself
all she does is post [ __ ] every
she deleted 60 000 tweets i mean
the woman's tweeted like so many [ __ ]
times it'll just be like look at me i'm
eating a taco
she can't handle people not looking at
her for five minutes
she doesn't have time to be a satanic
pedophile she's on twitter all day
so here's the thing she tweeted things
about that show toddlers and tiaras and
some of them are weird some of them are
creepy
she tweeted some things about pizza or
whatever nobody knew before pizzagate
people just liked
pizza they didn't know um i don't like
chrissy teigen i don't think she's funny
i think she's annoying
uh i don't like that she judged a comedy
competition
on um nbc there's nothing funny about
her and and i don't know why the hell
i'm going to jail over pizza i mean what
was that 2013 i mean she
well it that didn't age well didn't age
well
did mage well but she didn't know
or she did i don't know i don't know her
okay
i don't like i'm not like hanging out
with her and john legend but i don't
think they're eating children
i don't think her and john like if she
was a cannibal it would be the most
interesting thing about her how much
more interesting would this [ __ ] be if
she was eating children
which i'm against but again just on the
[ __ ] what makes people interesting if
somebody said you know that hot [ __ ]
chrissy teigen who's for some reason
hosting a comedy show on nbc
judging and telling people who's funny
and who's not funny
well and she has a cookware line and i'm
like yes
and they would go she's also a [ __ ]
cannibal
and i'm like really really
but i don't think she is she's just
trying to be funny
and when people that don't have any
perspective try to be
funny they just say things that are
outlandish
she's just a hot girl trying to get
attention okay so we're just talking
about eating human flesh
i would love to taste with a human it's
just when hot chicks talk
guys just laugh at whatever they say
anyone chrissy teague in her entire life
when she said something like i just want
to eat
people guys you'd be like yeah you're
you're cool
yeah people you're [ __ ] wild if i
said i want to eat people
someone goes and calls the police so
there's a difference
between me and chrissy teigen and how
people respond to what we say
she's never had to be accountable for
any word that's ever come out of her
mouth
she just hasn't because she's gotten
that hot chick we're just
ordinary cannibals what a great song
though
why not do that he's just playing in the
piano
we're the sargent eric animals
we just wanna eat our fill
just maybe lean into it i don't know i
don't know i don't
think she's eating chill why do we why
do the kids have
why is sexual abuse not enough for the q
am people
why is it not enough that the kids are
being sexually abused that is
heinous horrific should be like
punishable by death
why is that not enough why do they have
to be eating the children
i don't understand why this has to be a
hansel and gretel fairy tale
for anyone to care about this
is what epstein anders lane doing was
that somehow better because they weren't
barbecuing
the girls after i don't understand
do you have to bring out a human-sized
rotisserie for people to care about
children it's very strange
very strange to me this obsession with
the celebrities being cannibals
i think if you just have a very shitty
life
or you're bored and your life's actually
pretty good
but you're bored you just start thinking
that
everybody who's achieved any level of
success eats people
i don't know what breaks in your mind i
don't know what happens
is chrissy teigen in the illuminati how
embarrassing
is it if this [ __ ] is
the thing that you all think like can
you imagine
doesn't that bother some of you
that it's this woman a woman who gets in
cookware feuds
with other with the food bloggers
but i think she should probably get off
twitter or take a little break chrissy
you're not built for it
relax she's big on twitter i sub tweeted
her once and said something and people
are like whoa
don't [ __ ] around with chrissy
they said she'll get you thrown right
off twitter
and i said why i said i'm just an
ordinary cannibal
[Music]
i feel bad for people that are suffering
from mental illness i want to say that
and i think there's a lot of people in
this country uh
all over the place that this quarantine
has exacerbated
mental illness including many of my
friends and family members and a lot of
people of my colleagues seem
seem to be uh slipping and losing their
mind okay
very sad alright peter brian kell and
brandon child who both died this morning
of coronavirus
very sad they fought till the end they
fought
till the end and i respect that
i respect that
i just want to scream about ordinary cat
i started watching this show
uh devon and ida came over we did the
patreon and i started watching this show
my big fat american gypsy
wedding i've become fascinated with
gypsies and i think everyone should get
a hobby during quarantine i really do i
think you should get a hobby
do something better yourself i've chosen
gypsies
you can choose losing weight writing a
novel
i've chosen the romani people that is
what i wanna and and listen to any of
them listening
don't curse me stop right there
because i am afraid of that i'm gonna
talk about this very respectfully
i don't want any of the curses i don't
think they run anything else so i don't
really have to worry about them denying
me you know
a spot on tournament of last two
but i you know no if the curses are
legit none of that i don't want any of
it
they're obviously the gypsies they've
been travelers forever a lot of people
think they're thieves
i don't i don't i don't know about that
i who am i there you make a little
business here it doesn't work out you
get in the caravan you go to the next
town what about
hey i don't have anything to say about
that
but they love like gaudy over-the-top
uh dresses and bling and and
and and they have these weddings that
are wild and these women
show up in these [ __ ] you know truly
heinous don't curse me heinous
grotesque outfits i mean thing can we
show screenshots
just google sandracelli who's the
designer of these outfits this
this woman who's not a gypsy but makes
her living
selling these people uh dresses to wear
to weddings and i mean
dresses that like look at look at these
i mean i mean
you'd have to be on crack to walk down
an
aisle in that but they love it and
they're
and a lot of them marry like their first
cousin
a lot of them do and i'm fine with that
i'm fine with that don't curse me
i just want you to be happy and they're
very open about that i'm not
now is there then there's the charge if
it gets a little inbred if you're
marrying your first cousin
and and and hey i don't know i'm not a
doctor
but i i it's just such a great show it's
just such a phenomenal show
tlc just finds groups of people and just
everything on tlc is just you find
people whose lives have been destroyed
my 600 pound life my strange addiction
i mean tlc has a room of executives
basically going like let's find a [ __ ]
who's addicted to eating a couch
let's find somebody who's addicted to
eating glass
and it's destroying the lining of her
stomach and her esophagus
and let's put her on and let's put her
on camera
and then they found these small groups
of american gypsies
and they have weddings and they get
these feuds and they beat the [ __ ] out
of each other
and uh i just i you know i thought
somebody told me about this show and i
thought i'd watch it for like a few
minutes i ended up watching just
at least a youtube clip after youtube
clip after youtube but they
are fun they seem fun i don't know if
they're the brightest but they seem
fun people like they're they're happier
than anyone i know
and many of them don't have much but
they're
happier than anyone i know so maybe they
figured it out
i don't know i'm being very careful here
because i don't know if or i believe in
the curse or not do you believe in the
gypsy curse
you're a [ __ ] texas you come out of a
deeply conservative christian church you
believe in all this [ __ ]
i mean where do you stand at ken gypsies
curse people i think so
i'm superstitious aren't you like do you
do you see omens and stuff or like i
don't want to start problems here
that's all i'm trying to say a million
of them right 10 million gypsies i don't
know how many
there are of them i'm just saying
i respect your culture i want to get
this guy pat baby on the show
whose daughter priscilla is a
professional uh wrestler
i'm i the culture is fascinating to me i
don't love the dresses but i'm not
gonna get married in a wedding dress
so it's i mean these wedding dresses at
first
i mean when you look at them they're
horrific
they're almost scary let me find that
snow white one
yeah they're almost they're kind of
terrifying
and a lot of these weddings are in
fields
if you are a gypsy fan of the show
please reach out to me and let's start a
dialogue
about how i can kind of
understand and learn more about the
gypsy culture
yeah i mean look at that i mean it's
just
it's kind of it's a little disturbing
it lights up too at night it also lights
up yeah but they love the bling and the
rhinestone i mean
so if you're a fan of the show and
you're a ramachal
ramneshal gypsy i don't really want the
irish traveler variety no offense
but i kind of want the real deal on the
show yeah
if you are a fan of the show and you're
on michelle gypsy
and that's possible
correct please respectfully
without cursing me
reach out because i'm just very
interested in the culture i just all i
want to watch is gypsies now
i mean it's crazy i just want to watch
gypsies
i just watch gypsy weddings gypsy balls
i don't i don't know what's happening to
me but i don't want to consume any other
content
at the moment except gypsies
there's something about it that i enjoy
i think of myself kind of like a
traveler
i'm a nomadic person to a degree am i
not you are
i've been persecuted throughout history
for being correct about everything
why why do i not get to you know what i
mean
they're they're happy people they're
they're interesting people
are they inbred that's a that's a fair
question
that i i am not weighing in on
in any way it's a question that i am
asking because the for
is if you marry your first cousin what
is that it's it's incest
yeah but but you know let's not
come down on it hard too hard on the
show let's just
let it out as like uh i think chrissy
teigen's the real problem
and but you know i don't know it seems a
little
it seems a little sus
i don't have a hot first cousin
i can't relate um but there's a look
that a lot of these people have there is
a look of that there's something
going there's maybe something a little
off not all of them haven't seen all of
them but certainly the ones on the show
some are pretty uh no
not it's
in unique there's an interesting
quality there
but i'm i'm actually just fascinated by
the culture i've only seen the gypsies
on the show
i don't know gypsies in real life i'm
not trying to discriminate against them
i i've i understand that all kinds of
people have all kinds of issues out
there
i don't a cousin marriage is not even in
the any of the in the top 100 problems
in america
and it's not even a problem do your
thing
um it's it's an interesting culture the
the the dresses
are a little strange um and
they beat they beat the [ __ ] out of each
other at a lot of these parties like
because they don't like when the gypsy
marries the non-gypsy it's called the
gorger
so the non-gypsy is called the gorgeous
and then there's the gypsies
i don't know what it is i'm just saying
well we're not going to talk about this
for the whole episode because i don't
need i don't need a [ __ ]
old woman coming over here and [ __ ] i
don't know
handing me a monkey's paw and cursing me
and maybe that doesn't happen i don't
know
but so here's what i will say if you are
gypsy and you want to like
you want to get involved with some
contact tracing call scams i would get
involved with you
i would fly to florida and set up a call
center right now with gypsies
with gypsies listen to call
people that and say that they've been
exposed to chronovirus and get their
information
just throwing it out there but other
than that i will just continue to watch
every episode of this show the uk and
the american version that i can
because it is truly the only thing that
is making me happy i mean it's truly the
only thing is about
i don't know why watching two women in
brightly colored dresses beat the [ __ ]
out of each other in a field
makes me happy but right now it is it's
hitting the spot
it's just hitting the goddamn spot we
all got to find
moments of levity we all got to find
things i'm enjoying
learning about different cultures isn't
that the point of life
learning about different cultures that's
what i'm doing on this
show that's why i watch my big fat
american gypsy wedding
to learn about different people and
their way of life
so if you're a romney shell gypsy not a
traveler i'm kidding if you're an irish
traveler
please message me on instagram and now
many of you
are going to lie because everyone always
lies when i say message me and they lie
and i know you lie
and i said are you in a secret society
and then you losers like yes i'm in
skull bones
we know you're not get your dick suck
get your dick sir get your dick sir
it's the apocalypse this episode of the
tim miller show is sponsored by
blue chew remember the days when you
could always go
remember the days when you had a job and
a family in life you could go places
remember the days when everybody wasn't
your enemy a vector of disease remember
those days remember the days when you
could gather in public remember those
days
when you could hug people and touch them
where you could lean on a surface
without having to
put hand sanitizer all over yourself you
had to rub yourself with ethyl alcohol
every five minutes you smell like a
distillery
going down the block remember those days
before the race riots and the war and
the looting and the famine and the
children
screaming out in the street remember
those days where are those days where
your [ __ ] was hard
blue chew brings you the first chewable
with the same fda approved ingredients
as viagra and cialis
you can take them any time day or night
even on a full stomach since their
chewable hence the name they work up to
twice as fast as a pill so you can be
ready whenever an opportunity arises
if you could benefit from more
confidence where it counts bluetooth
fast and easy way to enhance your
performance
bluetooth is prescribed online by
licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office or wait in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door
in a discrete package so if you like a
harder dick
and you have a little erectile
dysfunction which everybody has and if
you don't you're just crazy because
people you know i mean you got to be
struggling right now with many different
things so i'm sure that uh some of that
ends up
hurting your performance and they're
made in the usa born in the usa
my dick pills in the usa
my brother can't get a hard [ __ ]
he jerks off the pawn in assad
he's on 4chan he is an isle
finally he met a woman and he doesn't
know what to do
take the blue chew it's made in the usa
[Music]
blue chew in the usa
right now we have a special deal for our
listeners
visit bluetooth.com and get your first
shipment free
wow when you order special
uh promo code i am hold on i'm getting a
phone call right now
hello tim this is dustin calling from
ocean prime in beverly hills
hi dustin how are you good how are you
i just have a question really quick so
the gift card you're telling me about
it's an ocean prime gift card right
it is yes is this okay i just need to
double check
thank you very much you're welcome all
right bye
[Music]
i mean these people has everyone had
their brain eaten
b-l-u-e true.com promo code t-i-m to try
it free
all you pay is five dollar shipping so
this is a great opportunity to try out
a nice little enhancement pill get a
nice hard penis
and it's truly great
blue chew is the better cheaper faster
choice we thank them if you like the
show
and you want um you know
he was drunk in a bar last night
he wanted to [ __ ] and not fight
but he brought a waitress home and he
took his pants down
and she looked at that mush and she
started to frown
blue chew in the usa
blew true in the usa
his dick looked like a prince
um that's b-o-u-e-chu dot-com
promo code tim to try it free
b-o-u-c-h-e-w-chew.com promo code tim
to try free thank you folks nate bergman
is back he's making his first solo music
that's already been described by classic
rock magazine as otis redding cross with
bruce springsteen
and make and that's because he does
blackface uh making instantly likable uh
tunes that hold their own the british
press metal hammer uk says bergman is
one of the most unique original voices
in modern music
and distorted sound describes his first
solo show in london as a draw
dropping performance american songwriter
says he's painfully honest witty lyrics
that are delivered through powerhouse
vocals
so nate bergman was in a band called
lionize they were successful he's a fan
of the show he's been
a listener for a long time he's made
music he's taken things we've said and
made some beautiful songs about them
and we're plugging his patreon here okay
music is being offered exclusively
through patreon
at patreon.com nate bergman sings
n-a-t-e
b-r-e-b-e-r-g-m-a-n
nate bergman sings n-a-t-e-b-e-r-g-m-a-n
nate bergman sings for just five dollars
a month the patreon features exclusive
studio songs live streams guitar
tutorials
and weekly stories about life from
inside the music industry and stories
from 18 years
on tour so if you're into guitar and you
want to learn how to play guitar with an
actual musician
who's a fun guy that does this for a
living nate bergman sings
he's on twitter he's on instagram you
can follow this guy
we just played his song on the show okay
if you like his music and even if you
don't you just want to help me
then follow him on twitter or follow him
on instagram so he doesn't
so he doesn't think this is a waste of
money you know
uh be a fan of his he's very talented
you should be a fan of his for fans of
neil young plink
pink floyd jason ispel black crows bruce
springsteen tom petty
nate is a rothschild member of the
patreon and has been a fan and supporter
for many years
the song middle of the end was inspired
by the episode of the tim dillon show
with ray kump
that song and living on the line are
available now only
on patreon so we're a big supporter of
independent creators
that go out and put their music out
there and they try to sell
finance everything bergman is a cool
dude uh his website is
nate bergmansings.com it's through
wix when they were sponsored we
appreciate that
n-a-t-e-b-e-r-g-m-a-n-sings.com
okay i really like a lot of his music
and and i'm sure i'd like a lot more of
it if i've heard it um
you know you should get into music it
might be a time to learn how to play
guitar on patreon why not hit the guy up
and say hey i want to play guitar maybe
you're sick of hitting your wife
maybe she's got the message you know and
maybe you wanna and the kids have gotten
the message
and they're all cowering in a corner
crying and you wanna learn how to play
the guitar
might be a good thing to put your hands
on instead of your woman
gays also beat each other up that people
don't think that but gays
really beat each other up a lot i don't
beat anyone i'm just saying people
people in gay relations hit each other
again nate bergman is a singer and uh
should be respected uh and if you enjoy
what he does
follow him on patreon you know i mean he
puts himself out there we appreciate it
um and uh you know just so follow him on
twitter
instagram go to his patreon if you're
into it
if you want to learn how to play guitar
listen to his music
um you know this is the future for
artists and uh we're uh
we're happy that he chooses to you know
put his stuff here
you know and i i disagreed with when he
did blackface and dressed up as otis
redding
i thought that was a bad move um
you know but he chose to do it
he chose to do it and uh he lives with
that
for the rest of his life we're kidding
of course he's
he's not done that that i know of but
who knows
nate bergman support him patreon.com
nate sings
accused by the i was accused and i won't
say the name but i was accused on
twitter by an ex-daily show writer of
using coded language
very disappointing very disappointing
truly disappointing this woman
who i've been nice to and like tweeted
out things she's done
because i think she has some talent
writing said like hey
you always seem like you're dancing
around what you want to say
um let it out we're all friends here i
think all of these people if you try to
have a nuanced point they all think
we're sitting in a room saying hi
hitler i don't know what's wrong with
this woman but this woman has a cooking
show
and i watched that and she made three
hitler jokes in the first minute
yeah so who's obsessed with hillary
maybe it's you i made a point and i made
the point on the show where i said that
people
that are you know very very
uncomfortable
and feel unsafe when people use language
they don't like or make points they
disagree with
seem to not mind they feel very safe
when you just have anarchy and chaos and
violence in the street
so i was like that seems like a very
interesting
setup for a human being psyche to have
getting triggered and feeling unsafe
with language but not really minding the
fire and the uh gunshots and the
violence
and then this woman was like well what
do you what do you really want to say
what did she think i was going to tweet
back oh right i'm sorry
heil hitler that's what i meant to say i
was making a nuanced point about
people weaponizing the word unsafe
to just basically shut down
conversations by saying they feel unsafe
and you rightly noticed that and called
me out because what i was
really saying is kyle hitler thank you
so much for pointing that out
and i said there i said i have i have a
lot of podcasts you can listen all of
them my words are very accessible
they're also my own and i said to her
you made a living at a major corporation
that vetted everything you said
everything you said went through
standards and practices you went through
ad sales
went through legal it got vetted it got
vetted
to make sure that it was okay because
[ __ ] corporate sponsors were sticking
ads in the middle of it
okay i'm allowed to say what the [ __ ] i
want and i say that
for now by the way for now uh i say that
and uh so all my words are pretty
accessible and they're my own they
didn't go through legal and
standards and practices and then she
doesn't respond of course because these
these people just want to drive the car
they want to throw the rock and they
want to keep going
that's what they want to do i pick up
the rock i throw it back by the time i
throw it back
the car is in the next town like the
gypsies
and i loved i love gypsy
don't waste a curse on me when chrissy
teigen's barbecuing kids
we just all right
i can't believe i have to defend chrissy
tegan 2020
[ __ ] you i don't want to defend chrissy
teigen i
hate her but i just don't think she's
eating
children i don't know
i'm gonna i'm gonna go on the but maybe
i don't know
i mean in two months if it comes out
she's eating children
i want to also make a disclaimer here
this is how [ __ ] things are
i have to now make a disclaimer that if
chrissy teigen
is busted for eating children i did not
know and i'm not defending her
i'm basically saying the evidence
presented at this point
has not convinced me that chrissy teigen
is a satanic
uh pedophile cannibal that being said
if new evidence comes i may revise my
estimate i don't know
i'm spending all my money right now
trying to get just slain maxwell out of
prison because she's been wrongly
accused
this is a powerful strong woman she's a
fierce advocate of women's independence
and liberation the idea that she's
behind bars right now is a [ __ ]
tragedy
it is a travesty it is disgusting and i
think we should get her out of jail
just lane maxwell did buy an ad this
week on the show
she did buy an ad this week on the show
and she it was
it was a lot of [ __ ] money we usually
don't sell ads for this much money
but it was an ad and it was it's an ad
for uh
her being released from prison and uh so
we do have to do the ad and this is just
essentially the ad is it just lane
maxwell wants to say hello to the whole
uh tim dylan trail fan base and audience
she thinks that there's a lot of rumors
floating around there about her
but they're easily corrected and uh
she'll be giving up some very big names
how great would it be if if just lane
maxwell's like they put her on the stand
finally whenever this trial happens it
won't by the way probably but whenever
it happens
she's like sitting there she's locked
listen love it's all chrissy teigen
we was working for chrissy teigen love
me and jeffrey wasn't doing nothing we
was afraid of chrissy taygan
how great would it be just just laying
just out's chrissy teigen
as the leader she is the leader
i went i had lunch at the yard house
in rancho mirage the yard house which is
uh
you know people know i love a corporate
steakhouse they know that
but i also you know every now and then
just a chain corporate lunch spot where
they do things like tuna ahi tuna pokey
nachos
and a nice crab cake sandwich with a
jalapeno tartar some truffle fries you
never leave
mad you never leave those places mad
let's be honest
you never leave that kind of outdoor
mall chain
lunch spot you know whatever it is mad
you know like a little up market not an
applebee's per se but like
a place with just a little bit more i
don't like the term gastropub
i've been highly critical of gastropubs
i think many of them suck
but i think some of them if done right
and some of and it's rare that it's
really done right
but some of these like craft brew houses
all this [ __ ] they just have good
food so there's a shout out
to the yard house and rancho mirage with
the aji
tuna poke nachos and the crab cake
sandwich phenomenal
uh sadly dickey's barbecue pit in rancho
mirage
still running a human trafficking ring
so if the victimization of children
bothers you go over and show dickies how
you feel about it
however you want to handle it just
handle it it's not my it's not my
business
but when you take a postmates order when
you have [ __ ] eight minutes and then
you [ __ ] call back and go
we're closed it's like you're not closed
i ordered it eight minutes ago
i'm just i'm a little i support the
american worker
and i have always it's something that i
believe it but i'm also getting very
angry
at the people in in drug stores that are
now using covet as a reason to not just
show you
where the the ear drops are like they
just
they just they point in general
direction they go they're over there
i'll say it's like
just show me where it is walk me to the
ear drop
point at it and then leave and i'll pick
it up
i just think that covet in general is
really bringing out the worst in
everybody including many of the people
that i have to deal with on a day-to-day
basis
you know and i'm just wondering how
should we handle this kind of level of
insubordination
or this new like attitude that a lot of
people have do we withhold a vaccine
from the people that are not performing
i mean there's a question i mean do we
withhold uh
treatment from the people that are not
performing
you know i mean is this the way to do it
because i think there's just a lot of
there's a lot of tude now there's a lot
of tude
and it's like uncalled for and
unnecessary i know you're miserable and
you don't want to be there and
you know you're being exposed to a
deadly virus and i get all of that but
like
here's the reality i i don't want the
tude
i don't want the dude i was all like
sanders working people support
but then i'm like i need an ear drop
because i got water in my inner ear
from the pool which is not as big as i'd
like but i
it's in my inner ear now and that will
cause an infection where are the drops
and it just point to aisle seven and go
yeah aisle seven and then walk away it's
like
what is this
where is the pride
ride aid in palm desert where is the
pride
no truly
it just bothers me i i i just think
that if people at certain jobs knew that
they would not be
vaccinated unless their performance was
better
they would rise to the occasion yes or
yes
yes or yes it's a question
i'm just throwing it out there how do we
mandate performance now
i don't know but i'm saying i think
maybe it's time
to kind of make people understand that
there are steaks
when i had that [ __ ] that's a fat crab
cake at the yard house with the jalapeno
tartar
and the poke nachos were nice they were
a little light on the ahi they're a
little light
but that's okay because i understand
that we're at reduced capacity we're on
only outdoor seating
i get it you're trying to make a buck
i understand that it's funny when you're
on the desert you always say like it's
hot
and all the locals like it could be like
116 degrees and
you'll be like it's hot and they're like
this is nothing it's like how hot does
it get
what do you mean this is nothing people
love to say that like locals love to say
they're like you don't know what odd is
it's like you know i is 116 degrees is
hot
that's hot oh you don't understand
you don't understand how bad things are
but shout out to that restaurant you
know it's it's uh
it's it's tough now to work in the
restaurant business it's very very
difficult i've only eaten outside we've
eaten outside at a few places
and my heart goes out to people in that
industry because it's an industry i'd
love to get into if if i was successful
at podcasting in a comedy
more so than i am now and i could save
some money i'd invested into a
restaurant i love that business and i
would like to
have a restaurant and i'd like to have
like a neighborhood casual
like a high-end upscale cafe i've talked
about it on the patreon
and so when i when i am at a restaurant
and i see
servers behaving in a way that just
isn't is it you know does it really uh
you know put the institution in a good
light i want
i want to take away their vaccines and i
want to and i
i want to make them i want to make them
understand that that can happen
and i just want to know how we can do
that as a country
uh to go to people at to the essential
well these are the essential workers
essentially the people the right
right age and the walgreens and the
nurses don't get me started on them but
i don't think i don't think the
essential workers should be vaccinated
if they're not the if they're i want a
peer review
i want a peer review like i want to know
that
that they're they're behaving like the
other day i ordered postmates
and the guy just opens the garage and
leaves it by the garage door
and it's it's like baking in the sun for
an hour and i'm yelling at postman
he doesn't knock on the door he doesn't
open the door
he sees that he goes in the garage and
leaves it in the [ __ ] garage
like should that guy be inoculated
against this disease
no no
i just i'm just saying
i think a lot of it had to do with
calling people heroes early on calling
them essential workers i think people
got a little bit of an attitude
i think people got got a little bit of a
chip on their shoulder when they heard
they were essential
and that people like myself were somehow
not essential the commentators the
people who speak the people who talk
the people who speak on behalf of the
people the voice of the voiceless i'm
not essential
but some clown is at trader joe's and i
think not i think not sir
sir i think not ma'am non-binary trader
joe's employee
i don't believe uh that you are
essential
and i think we just do a little chip on
the shoulder
and i'm not i am not
blind to the sacrifices that a lot of
those people have made
but what i am saying is that there needs
to be a standard of quality delivered
in every interaction no matter what
in the midst of rioting in the midst of
looting in the midst of a pandemic
in the midst of an economic collapse in
the midst of a political crisis
in the midst of a crisis in confidence
in government in the midst of an
escalation of a cold war hopefully
not a hot war with china in the midst of
all those things
i still [ __ ] think you get off your
fat ass
and you show someone where the eardrops
are
that's what i think and if you don't do
that you don't get
vaccinated
we made a sketch for tbs this week that
is so
ridiculous uh so embarrassing
um and we did it because we are
actually daring them to put it on
television
i cannot believe we made this catch we
made we have all the footage right yeah
we do
we're gonna cut together the sketch uh
we give all them the raw footage and
they cut it together the last catch we
gave them they completely butchered it
and they removed all contacts and it
didn't make any sense if you'd seen the
last catch was me and
devon we're sitting at a table it's
obviously two guys are having dinner
it's like you know with everything else
going on we're looking at our phones you
hear screams and everything they took
all that part out
it took like the context out you didn't
realize we were at a restaurant i mean
the whole thing was crazy
um again the editors at the editors at
tbs were
drawing a salary somehow to edit
content but the new sketch we gave them
is so
patently ridiculous so absurd truly it
shows how little respect we have for the
entire show
the entire institution of television
specifically basic cable
but i mean it is so cra i mean it is
almost the idea of it being on tv
just makes me laugh
i mean have we ever made anything that
crazy it was like freddy got fingered
but like
made less sense it doesn't make any
sense
somehow imagine if they like make it
make sense somehow every
every sketch we've given them has made
sense and they've made it
not make sense by their editing
decisions
um and you could vote for vote for us at
what tournament laughs or whatever i
mean i don't know let me give the link
out now if you want to vote and by the
way i don't care what you do i don't
care if you vote or not i just want to
watch
gypsies uh get married over and over
again
and and get the postmates orders i order
on time that's really all i want to do
until i die
and and the way things going is probably
all i will do who's left in the contest
you even know
who do we got left so we're we don't
know if we're in round three yet or no
we are in round three right
so that's the elite eight i don't know
if we're allowed to say that
they weren't around we didn't say it
what are they gonna do
sue us kicks off the show
thanks they sent me a promo the other
day to put up and i go i'm not in the
promo there you go
they go well everybody in the show is
not in the promo like well why am i
sharing it if i'm not in it
my fans are going to think i'm sharing
another [ __ ] show that they don't
want to watch
if i'm not in it how [ __ ] dense are
you people
how these people made money soon they
won't soon i think this this industry is
going to take a big haircut
and a lot of people that previously had
jobs in it will not have jobs
and and and very few of them should
currently have jobs
um but we don't know who's left how do
they vote for us
at the tbs tournament of laughs website
if you type in tournament of laughs into
google it'll take you on the first link
if you go to the tbs tournament of
laughs
website tbs.com
and then shows tournament of laughs they
will allow you to vote for
me and ben to continue advancing in this
contest
and i mean so when is the sketch that we
made i mean this abomination
it is funny but it's like an abomination
so that's if we make it to round four
around three sketches airing sunday i
think
so round three schedule air sunday which
is what that we can't say
like we can't say all right but you've
seen it you've seen it before
round four of tournament of laughs
is is the abomination yeah if the if it
happens
and if it doesn't happen we will release
the abomination
on the show we're gonna put all the
footage out
of what we filmed and then i guess you
will all see why it did not make it on
tv
but it might we might win and then they
have to figure out
something to do with it why we're
sending it in like this
so craig is that we want them to stare
at this
and be puzzled and not understand what's
happening and then have to somehow edit
it into something
that can make sense on television
which i mean of all the things we've
made this is like by far
the most ridiculous yeah in round five
if we make it to round five you think we
should do something even weirder
if we make it to round five this is the
plan for the rest of the show
we're just going to do things that are
so insane
and so absurd and they they're going to
make less and less sense
that like i think what's the final round
one two three i think round six so if
round six
is the final round five maybe if round
five or six whatever it is
the final round i think it should just
be like me
sitting on a in a bathtub eating my own
[ __ ]
and then just like ben like screaming
in another language off camera
and then like we submit this and when
they call us they go ah
we're just having a problem i go what do
you mean like sitting in the bathtub
smeared with my own [ __ ] fake [ __ ] and
then just eating like fake [ __ ]
and then ben like in another language be
like
and like like five like three minutes of
it i think it has to be like a five
minutes no it'd be five minutes of that
and there's gotta be nothing like just
screaming like indian death chance or
you know like tibetan whatever prayer
you know and then i'm just like eating
my own [ __ ]
and then i just stand up and i go like
like we we want to make something
that is so disrespectful that we'll
never work in this business again
because we're bored i'm bored
so we just want to we just wanna get a
call from the executives at tbs
now the problem is the dumbest thing we
make the executives probably close up
and go this
is great this is actually great
[ __ ] tub on tbs and they're like we love
the idea of you sitting in a tub eating
your own [ __ ] can you do this
could you do this every week can like
diverse other cast members sit and eat
[ __ ] with you
so that's the problem now it's like the
producers where they made that you know
made that musical that ended up making a
lot of money
do you know what my favorite cereal was
a kid was what
lucky charms do you know why why
because it tasted like sugar i love
sugar because i was from a bad family
[Music]
and many kids are getting addicted to
sugar
and it is unfortunate many people have a
have a
crippling addiction in this country to
sugar
but i've lost 700 pounds
in the last year and do you know how
i've done that
no i started eating a cereal called
magic spoon
when i started this year i was a
thousand pounds and now i'm down to
felt around 300 probably under we don't
know
but it's all been because of magic spoon
cereal because every time i want a cocoa
fruity frosted snack
instead of going out and face [ __ ]
myself
with every available option of food what
i do
is i go and i eat some magic spoon and
you can get it by going to
magicspoon.com
tim dillon to grab a variety pack of
this
zero sugar are you ready for this wake
the [ __ ] up
zero sugar 12 grams of protein and only
three net
grams of carbs in each serving what's
your favorite cereal the fruity one
the magics no don't be a [ __ ] chill
for a minute
i'm trying to have a conversation with
you what's your actual favorite cereal
i like smacks smacks the one with the
frog yeah yeah
god you are a nazi
smacks has killed several people
it's true you know that you never heard
that the smack stroke
no no people have a stroke in the middle
of eating it and they go
and they drop to the floor ray comp
spoke
regular until he was eating smacks
smacks is not that good dude
i like it i mean it's really not that
good i haven't ever had it in 15. people
think i'm abusive to you but this is why
i'm abusive to him because he says
[ __ ] things
says stupid things not [ __ ] you know
what i mean i don't want to offend
anybody out there especially retards
this is a this is keto friendly cereal
it's gluten
free it's grain free soy free low carb
gmo free you've got to try magic spoon
to believe it because it tastes amazing
um you know i was i love golden grahams
i love lucky charms i love pops
i love i love honey nut cheerios king
[ __ ] honey nut cheerios
uh i didn't mind the [ __ ] you know a
cinnamon toast crunch
maybe a little waffle crisp here and
there but then you were starting to get
a little too ridiculous when you got
into that you know
um
but i'll tell you this when i eat magic
spoon i feel like i'm a kid again
yeah i feel like i'm a child again i
feel like
i'm stealing cigarettes from my friend's
mother and smoking them in a place we
called oil city
i feel like i'm taking a drive with a
guy named hector and sonia who were not
a couple but we're [ __ ] and then
later he found out she had a family i
feel like we're taking that car into
south jamaica queens to get cocaine from
a guy named albert
i feel like a child again like i feel
like a kid i feel like
i was uh you know me and my buddy were
dropping acid
on stage my eighth grade graduation i
feel like that type of
just kind of that innocent child like
life you know and
what takes me back there is when i eat
magic spoon cereal it takes me back to
when i had no cares in the world you
know except drug dealers i owed money
that had weapons
but i want people to truly try this
cereal do it for me
if you don't want to do it for your own
health do it for me right
because i knew
a woman who was a big big big girl
she was a big girl and they wanted her
to lose weight and she couldn't lose
weight because she just
kept eating uh sugar
and then she ordered the magic spoon
cereal and do you know who that woman is
today
melania trump okay
so understand what i'm [ __ ] saying
here
okay
do you understand what i'm saying every
epstein girl was
fed magic spoon cereal on the island
every single one
and they said that's the one part of
their experience that they don't regret
they said they'd go back there and take
allen wins down dershowitz's hog
if they could get that cereal again this
is a fact this is what they said i'm
reading court transcripts
okay don't get mad at me
the epstein victims said they would
gladly suck off alan dershowitz in his
old
schlong again which was unwashed per
them
if they could get a bowl of magic spin
cereal because that was what they saw
served everybody on the island because
they didn't want them to crash they
didn't want the sugar to crash
so they wanted people to be perky and
pepped up
naturally magic spoon
cereal it is the cereal the official
cereal
of little saint james magic spoon cereal
chiseling maxwell has said is so good i
can't believe it has no
[ __ ] sugar
that's from the mouth of that's from the
mouth of
you know the boss
i'm just saying go to magicspoon.com tim
dillon
if you want to eat the official cereal
of jeffrey epstein's island
do you understand me tim dillon at free
free shipping you get free shipping
dummy
you know how much it cost to ship that
little st james
they actually named magic spoon on
little saint james because there was a
trick where someone took a spoon
all right forget it but magic
it's a joke freddie was listening please
get [ __ ] lawyers leave me alone
magic spoon got go go go attack other
people here okay we got other people
i'm making jokes we've got other people
that need you to keep an eye on them in
this town not me
magicspoon.com tim dillon used the code
tim dillon for free shipping
and thanks to magic spoon for not only
sponsoring us
but sponsoring little st james and and
and uh
the official cereal of just like maxwell
thank you
you know me i've slept on [ __ ] shitty
mattresses i slept on couches
i [ __ ] my back up horribly and and now
i'm getting to the point where i say to
myself i need to treat myself right so i
got myself a helix mattress
okay if you can't sleep because of
today's politics
or the pandemics or fireworks or your
love life or any other drama
that's going on out there right now okay
you could easily sleeping in a terrible
mattress
can ruin your life sleep is the most
important thing in your life it truly is
it's not family
it's sleep you get sleep and you're
happy
if you don't have sleep you're uh you're
you're sleepy
so they have a quiz helix helix has a
quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences
to be the perfect mattress for you
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm
mattress is great for cooling you off if
you sleep hot
even a helix mattress for plus size
folks god help those people i took the
healer's quiz and was matched with a
model mattress because i wanted
something that felt
firm i like firm i sleep on my side
maybe not i don't even know so if you're
looking for a mattress you take the quiz
you order the mattress that you're
matched to
let me tell you right now this will
change your life
if you decide to commit to actually
sleeping the six to eight hours a night
that you need to
on a great mattress you're going to
change your life
you're happier healthier your your mind
is clear you don't have brain fog
helix sleep.com tim dillon
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
listen to that 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com this
mattress is so good
whatever ponzi scheme you're involved in
whatever horrible loveless marriage
you're in you're gonna sleep like a baby
this mattress is so good that people
outside breaking into your windows
trying to kill you are not gonna wake
you up
you'll die in your sleep it's so goddamn
good this mattress is so good
that the world will burn around you and
you will not so much as [ __ ] roll
over it is a good
mattress it's for the moment it is
exactly for the moment you will sleep
through
the dissolution of this country you will
sleep through the destruction
of every meaningful institution that you
hold here
you will sleep through the race riot and
the horrible
[ __ ] nightmare economic collapse
you'll sleep through the riding the
burning the looting you'll sleep through
the pandemic and the covet in the great
depressions and recessions you'll sleep
through
the bursting of the bubbles you'll sleep
through your wife
leaving you you'll sleep through your
son or daughter turning on you and
hating you
you'll sleep through your company
leaving you'll sleep through the
missiles that are coming from china
let's go to helix sleep.com
slash tim dillon take their two-minute
sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep
of your life but that's the update
god man i'm thinking about getting out
of la don't know if i will or not but i
mean
the thought always crosses my mind do i
do i end up on the west coast of florida
do i end up in florida in some swamp
i don't know texas i like texas a lot
too
you know new york has fallen uh
people just call each other now they're
like soho has fallen oh my god
like tribeca is being occupied i'm like
really
but yeah i think i think i think the the
journey to la may be coming to an end
you know i mean the clubs are closed
there's nothing really to do
um you know everybody makes fun of the
tick tock kids but they really
that's what la is you're supposed to be
20 and good looking and live in a house
with a bunch of your friends
and just [ __ ] a bunch of people and make
a lot of money and then by 30 it's all
uh
you know forgotten it's all like a dream
that happened and then you just have
some money and you have a hot wife you
have some kids you move down orange
county and you get into jesus
and you go to mosaic the rocker church
yeah and you know just like jesus
keep letting me make all this money
that's what the orange county church
mosaic is jesus
please keep me rich and powerful
help my swing help my golf swing
my wife has new kids thank you lord
and they're all they'd like dance around
it's all just rich white people dancing
around
like some of them are playing guitars
it's like you know jesus
is the first influencer type of church
uh but that that's the la life like
that's the la life and i'm never gonna
have that life
i'm never gonna be 20 and hot and living
in a cool house and being cool and then
moving orange county with my
uh you know fake tittied wife and then
get
going to like mosaic church and jumping
around and
that's what that's what la's supposed to
be or california in general
i just that's not gonna be for me so
but i could live a texas life like i
could live that life i could certainly
live a florida life
those two states intrigue me i like them
texas you don't have the state income
tax
um florida you don't have the state
income tax either
florida you do have floridians so that's
a little bit of a
an issue you know do i join the gypsies
do i join the roma do i join a traveling
group of people
who i respect don't curse me i don't
know these are these are all thoughts i
never thought this you know i moved to
la
about a year ago permanently and i got
passed at the comedy store about a year
ago
and then the entire world shut down and
collapsed
my entire business changed we've gone
through like a decade of evolution in a
few months
everybody has become digital uh you know
that's why the patreon is really cool
because you can have a lot of fun on the
patreon we get really wild on the
patreon
we're not worried about youtube yanking
us off we're not worried about any of
that
uh we get pretty wild here too and we
have fun on this show but like the
patreon is a great
i think that's just if you want
entertainment if you want better
entertainment
you're just gonna have to find find it
you're gonna have to seek it out you're
not gonna get it networks aren't gonna
give it to you
you're just gonna have to seek it out
it's probably gonna be behind a paywall
it's gonna have to be
because i'm gonna be like the people
that are on my patreon seek out my
comedy
so they're offended by something then
it's their fault you know what i mean
it's like
it's like if i go into gucci to try to
get jeans and they're like we don't have
a size 44 and i'm like what do you mean
it's my fault you don't go to gucci go
to dxl the fat person store
i went to the fat person's toy the other
day and the guy was like do you ever
work retail
i was like no because i mentioned
something about the fat store on beverly
hills and clothes
and he's like he's like we hated the
people at the fat store in beverly hills
they're like
they used to send us all their rejects
like clothing wise yeah you know to this
other fat store
like what am i going to hear about this
now
i'm going to hear about a few to fat
stores
this is the year 35 of my life
this is the year 35 i get to stand here
and have this guy talk to me about the
feud he's having with the other fat
store
in beverly hills and i'm like well all
the fat stores should stick together
but they don't there's feuds there's all
kinds of problems
so what are you going to do
folks you got to stay positive stay up
stay positive that's what i do i just
stay positive and
what works for me is it working out is
it eating well is it religion no
i like gypsies
i like watching them and learning about
them that's what's doing it for me right
now
it's not [ __ ] avocado toast and it's
not a nine mile run
but it is watching gypsies get married
in a field that is what makes me
happy i suggest you watch that show my
big fat greek
no my big fat gypsy american wedding
even though
i want to watch the uk one as well
because the uk one i think is very good
uh two you know again i'm not
i'm not throwing shade marry your cousin
do what you want to do you know they
they all seem to have a little bit of uh
you know
that they're that that's you know
prevalent i think in the community is
that they are
they marry extended family and maybe you
know
and that's okay and i mean those dresses
they're wild they're they're to me they
they make me
they make me feel sick in a good way
like when you first take shrooms
yeah like i'm like sick to my stomach
but in a happy way i don't know why
i'm like happy that that's happening
you know i'm not knocking anybody
but because i am
i'm afraid to look personally
i mean i'm truly i'm truly i'm like
literally terrified
uh that they will curse me and i will
end up uh overweight
or something like that i do not want
that wouldn't it be great if this is
just a curse this whole
culvert was just a gypsy curse oh we're
already cursed we're ready cursed
i don't know where should i live where
should i go you're allowed to submit
suggestions to me
you know tell me where you think i
should live where should i go where
should we move this operation
where should we go i don't know
it's a good question maybe stay here
maybe we'll stay in la
i'm trying to get maybe maybe they'll
let me in maybe the hype house will let
me into sway house to tick-tock houses
i don't know it's just so it's
that's when you should be like these
19-year-old morons that are driving
around in tesla's have no idea
they have no clue that's what la's about
ellie's about having no clue
it's a city you can really only enjoy if
you don't have any clue
and you're just like things go fast
powder goes up nosy
that's it penis goes in hole
if if you have any thoughts about
anything
you got to get out of here it's not a
city of thoughts
it's not a city of thoughts new york now
it's hard to have a thought because as
you're having it a
bullet grazes your skull that is also a
problem
bill de blasio really destroying that
city
i mean and by the way none of this none
of this
ignores the bungling of the corona the
incompetence of government stealing
not giving people money i mean everyone
could call this they gave people twelve
hundred dollars
nobody's getting unemployment anymore in
a few weeks that runs out
people are on the verge of it you know i
mean all of this
ev everything my criticisms of like de
blasio people yeah
i always understand
really the genesis of this issue which
is that we have
people just too [ __ ] greedy in this
country
and they're unwilling to compromise it
all and
and allow people to live dignified lives
which is what we need to do
people can be rich people can own
multiple homes people but
you need to invest in an education and
and health care
and have an infrastructure that allows
people to live dignified lives if you
rob them of their dignity
and you destroy that and they're and
they're selling homes and going bankrupt
because they get sick
i mean it's it's in a moral
system and both republicans and
democrats have participated in that for
a long time
in a moral system that i said on twitter
deserves to be burned down
the system but when you start burning
down like individual buildings
one owned by like an indian woman who's
like what what you know
that's what she sounded like it's it's
wrong and it doesn't help anything and
then what happens
then a few weeks later we have dhs
agents uh running around grabbing people
off the street because
that do you not know where we live
are you not are you unaware do you think
these high school kids in portland that
are now starting this youth liberation
front
of portland i mean do you really think
those guys are going to be able to stand
up
against i mean the true power of the
state it's just it's not gonna happen
and i don't understand why people think
it's gonna happen
or that it or that we wanna be ruled by
high school students from portland
is that i don't understand
people just keep defending the displays
of
clear violent which like they're going
up to people
and and starting and intimidating people
and saying like say black lives matter
you've got a group of people
that are intimidating somebody you're
trying to get them to say
something you're under the threat of
violence what is that doing
what causes that helping why are people
defending that
why is the media egging that on
why is the media pretending that these
two people who looked
funny they looked buffoonish but walking
out of their house with weapons and
standing there
whilst people walked by their home why
is the media pretending that those two
people are like terrorists
when they literally just walked on to
the front of their house with weapons
i don't understand was it an
overreaction potentially
but it's their home and it's their
weapons why is the media you know and
then i think
the weapon was confiscated i think that
guys akford there ak-47s
were confiscated why are we cheering
that on
i don't understand why are we cheering
on people's inability to defend
themselves
do you think the people in the street
are always going to agree with you
do you believe that do you really
believe that dude when you sleep
at night in your bed when your head hits
the pillow uh do you think that the
people
in the street are always going to have
your
back and that you would never need to
defend yourself
you think the government on the other
side you think the government's always
going to have your back
you think any institution in america is
none of them truly every major
institution
in this country does not care about you
and they will let you die
fact so anybody ridiculing anybody's uh
means of how they protect themselves or
self-defense
is crazy anybody ridiculing anybody
uh you know it just makes no sense to me
every major institution this country
from the government
to the media to the police everybody
is not focused on your rights
as a citizen they're all in some larger
battle against something else some
larger ideological war
and you as a citizen as an individual
don't matter and they'll let you die
they'll let you die trust me on either
side
everywhere cops are going to let you die
to make a point about rising crime
people in the street may kill you to
make a point that they need to use
violence to get what they want
government may kill you just because
that's what the government does
the media may publish your address and
have people dox you
they may put out a false narrative about
you
that goes around the world before you're
able to defend yourself you may lose
your job you may lose your family you
may lose your career
you may lose you the place you live in
and the media will not give a [ __ ]
they'll move on but none of those
institutions care about you as an
individual what your rights are as a
citizen it's true
it's a fact your friends may care your
family may care
care about yourself but none of those
institutions they're all
corrupt all of them and none of them
have any focus on your life as an
individual
and your family and your ability to work
and live
and and or whatever you want to do
and so the idea is when you start
ridiculing people
who have the means to defend themselves
from any and
of the above mentioned
you know power factions when you start
ridiculing those people
i mean man you must have some faith you
must have a lot of faith
in these systems i don't you must have a
lot of faith
if you're sitting there if you're a type
of person who's not thought about even
maybe getting a gun over the last three
or four months
good for you but also that's a lot of
faith
it's a lot of faith you know
you know and if you're a person who
thinks that the state
cares about you or that trump cares
about you or that
trump gives a [ __ ] about you
right now when all he tweets is law and
order as the cities burn
and he tweets law and order you think
that guy cares
good for you but i would [ __ ]
you know it's time to
start really understanding that like a
lot of what we've been talking about
for the last couple of years or a lot of
what very smart people have been telling
you what's gonna happen is happening
it's not a drill not a fire drill
where the alarms pulled and everybody
goes stands in the parking lot and
everybody goes back
this is not a drill this is the
disintegration
of society in front of your eyes
and it will be probably the introduction
into a dystopian uh
surveillance state police state
that we will live in and it might take
us a few years of chaos to eventually
arrive at that point
which may be the plan but this is the
beginning of that
seeing writers leave newspapers and
magazines
is it doesn't mean anything to any of us
but
make no mistake it's the beginning
it's the beginning of an orwellian
nightmarish control system that they're
going to put in
where you're ridiculed for speaking and
you're ridiculed for
having the temerity to defend yourself
or even brandishing a weapon and saying
yeah i have the ability to defend myself
the idea that that you would be uh
ridiculed for that i mean you could be
made fun of i tweeted the picture out i
said when doordash
i drew the picture i was like when
doordash was [ __ ] around they were
standing there it was funny
you know but the idea that people are
cheering on the they're confiscating of
their weapons which i believe were
legally owned
and the idea that people are cheering
that on again it's just
i don't know what you think is coming
i really don't i'm unaware of what you
think is coming because the adults in
america
have have like left it's
really it's just the case i mean
imagine a high school party the adults
are gone
everybody is running [ __ ] wild
people are falling through tables
there's broken glass people are trying
to sweep things up
there's fights breaking out people are
trying to figure out who did what
the kid who owns the house is oding in
the bathtub he's throwing up people
trying to lift his head up
nobody who knows who that kid even is
everybody's trying to find him
it's an absolute [ __ ] nightmare you
know
you're kind of having fun because the
party's still kind of fun
you know the party's still kind of fun
even though things are getting out of
control quickly and then the cops come
in
and shut the party down i mean we're
we're at that party
we're at that party now okay
and and the kid who owns the house is
tweeting out law and order
as the house is burning and as the vases
are smashing
and there's people that we don't know
are just coming in the house and [ __ ]
your little sister
and he's locked in the bathroom tweeting
law and order
it's not a good look and i don't know
what comes next
but i'll tell you where i'm gonna be
with aroma